[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 2 novembre 2009
un protocole sanitaire renforcée port du
masque obligatoire dès le cp et minute
de silence ce matin pour 12 millions
d'élèves dans les écoles pour rendre
hommage à l'enseignant assassiné samuel
pâtit une rentrée particulière alors que
le conseil scientifique a prédit un
hiver avec plusieurs vagues de
coronavirus bercy annonce une tolérance
jusqu'à mercredi pour la vente de
produits non essentiel en grandes
surfaces alors qu'enflent la polémique
sur la fermeture des petits commerçants
en plein confinement
[Musique]
veillez de présidentielle aux états unis
ce lundi marque l'ultime jour de
campagne donald trump dénoncent des
sondages site bidon et se dit confiant
dans sa victoire
plus de 90 millions d'électeurs se sont
déjà prononcés soit par correspondance
soit dans un bureau de vote anticipé et
l'issue du scrutin reste incertain bien
que certaines sondages donnent une
avancée au candidat démocrate joe biden
nous retrouverons dans cette émission
stéphanie de murs eu notre envoyé
spécial à washington elle suit pour nous
cette campagne
[Musique]
les propos d' emmanuel macron défendant
le droit à la caricature au nom de la
liberté d'expression les émirats arabes
unis soutiennent la france alors que le
président a dénoncé des manipulations de
ses propos y compris par certains
dirigeants
dans un entretien enregistré en français
vendredi auprès de la chaîne qatarienne
al jazeera à la colère du monde musulman
ne retombe pas comme au bangladesh
[Musique]
et on débute avec les derniers chiffres
du coronavirus en france santé publique
france dénombre 50 2518 nouveaux cas de
contamination au co vide en 24 heures
c'est un nouveau record à 416 personnes
sont décédées à l'hôpital toujours ces
dernières 24 heures et puis 430 patients
ont été admis en réanimation et c'est
dans ce contexte que les grandes
surfaces devront finalement fermé leurs
rayons non essentiels à partir de
mercredi selon bercy qui annonce une
tolérance
les petits commerces restent clos en
cette période de confinement nationale
une mesure qui a tendance à faire débat
alors qu'en pense réellement les
français jonathan moa dab est allé à
leur rencontre
regardez c'est jonathan noah dab est
allé à leur rencontre
regardez je suis un peu choqué parce que
je trouve que que les petits commerçants
il faut les laisser travailler et c'est
inadmissible effectivement que les
grandes surfaces ou amazon peut vendre
n'importe quoi et pas nos petits
commerçants et je suis complètement
d'accord avec tous les maires qui ont
déposé un décret pour que leurs petits
commerçants puissent ouvrir les font ce
qu'ils peuvent
la situation est critique il faut bien
fermer quelque chose c'est gym est
exactement ce qu'on veut on peut
toujours trouver qu'il ya des exceptions
qui vont tomber dans son ensemble il
faut qu'ils peuvent et on aurait déjà dû
fermer probablement que se veulent
plutôt quoi il me semble démesuré d'art
et essai ce petit et tous les petits
commerçants qui vont se trouver dans des
situations
vraiment extraordinaire vers des burnout
extraordinaire aussi desquelles ils
pourront pas se relever
il faut qu'on soutienne du coup les
petits commerçants donc faut peut-être
peut-être laissé les s'est laissé ses
petits commerces
faire dérouler leur travail car il est
leur business tout en maintenant du coût
des gestes-barrières les mesures de
sécurité nécessaires mais je trouve que
c'est une décision radicale de les
fermer
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose de
scandaleux qui consiste à laisser
ouvertes les grandes surfaces est par
contre en fait les petits commerces qui
jouent leur survie eux ne peuvent pas
ouvrir ils peuvent très bien s'entourer
de de précaution par exemple ne faire
entrer que quatre personnes dans leur
boutique ou 3 ou 2 même si il faut là
c'est une période extrêmement importante
pour eux c'est une honte parce que les
petits commerçants ont besoin d'eux
de vivre ils ont besoin d'eux et
d'être soutenus et à l'heure actuelle
ils ne sont pas compris ils sont mis de
côté et c'est c'est lamentable
vraiment alors on annonçant la fermeture
des rayons non essentiels dans les
grandes surfaces par mesure d'équité
jean castex tente donc d'éteindre la
polémique sur la fermeture à des petits
commerces durant le confinement mais le
désarroi l'incompréhension et la colère
prédominent les commerçants veulent
pouvoir ouvrir tous les commerces dès le
13 novembre
alors cette nouvelle période de
fermeture peut-elle sonné le glas des
petits commerces un décryptage tout de
suite avec nos invités et pour en parler
nous sommes avec corinne in estime
résidente de la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises de la
région sud provence alpe côte d'azur
bonsoir avec vous ce soir jean philippe
dugoin clément mais rudy de mennecy vice
président de la région ile de france en
charge de l'environnement nous a rejoint
également alexis poulain éditorialistes
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france corinne
et steve je me tourne vers vous la vente
des produits non essentiels sera donc
interdite dans les grandes surfaces par
souci d'équité on le disait avec des
petits commerces
une mesure qui prendra effet mercredi
puisque le gouvernement a annoncé cet
après midi une tolérance jusqu'à
mercredi dans ces grandes surfaces
finalement le terme équité employés par
le gouvernement
est ce vraiment le cas selon vous alors
absolument pas d'ailleurs les
témoignages que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure
vont dans le sens de ce que à la cpe
alors moi je suis présidente de l'adie
des parts de l'âme de mythe et
départementales du 13-mai effectivement
ce que je vous disais c'est que c'est ma
jument majoritairement très mal ressenti
qu'on ne vous permettent pas aux petits
commerçants des trouvères n'avait pas
demandé forcément la fermeture des
rayons non essentiels dans les grandes
surfaces
parce que bien évidemment celui qui en
bénéficie et bien c'est encore une fois
amazon ou douane tous les géants du net
c'est-à-dire que les achats vont se
reporter sur l'achat en ligne
nous nous demandions de prendre en
considération tous ces commerces qui
depuis le premier confinement ont
investi dans les gestes barrières les
équipements sanitaires ont mis
thématiquement place tout ce que le
gouvernement leur a toujours dit de
faire dans les commerces où justement on
va en général en petit nombre
donc on n'a jamais pu prouver non plus
que dans ces commerces
on a pu être contaminées et on les rend
responsables en quelque sorte et le plus
dramatique c'est que c'est à la veille
d'une période charnière pour eux puisque
les achats de noël représente pour la
majorité entre 20 et 60% selon le type
d'activité de leur chiffre d'affaires
annuel
donc c'est vraiment la double peine
cette mise en place de la fermeture
un amendement a été voté par le sénat et
nous cpm 13 nous avons beaucoup insisté
auprès des députés parce que demain le
vote
elle sera dans leurs mains et on a bien
insisté auprès d'eux et on a vu avec
courage pour bien deux maires ont pris
la décision tout en sachant que ça
pouvait être effectivement cassé par le
préfet mais ont montré leur attachement
au commerce juste devant justement
corinne estime à un maire avec nous ce
soir on va en parler tout de suite juste
avant que vous propose d'écouter les
mots de la ministre du travail j'entends
le désarroi et la colère des petits
commerçants
mais si on ouvre les commerces il n'y a
plus de confinement il faut que chacun
s'empare des outils qui existent mais
continuer à faire ses courses comme
avant comme si de rien n'était ne sera
pas possible dans l'immédiat
plus le confinement sera efficace plus
on pourra rouvrir vite les commerces
alors elisabeth banc mais aussi le
ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire qui ont jugé
irresponsable et maires qui sont montés
au front avec des arrêtés d'ouverture
jean philippe dugoin clément vous êtes
mais rudy de mennecy comment est-ce que
vous réagissez quand vous entendez ces
maires jugés irresponsables par le
gouvernement déjà je trouve que ces
ministres devraient faire attention au
terme qu'il emploie quand le président
de la république vient encore une fois
faire appel aux maires quand on mesure
le poids et l'importance qu'ont eue les
élus locaux pour essayer de faire en
sorte que le premier confinement se
passe bien
la première des responsabilités de la
part de madame byrne monsieur le maire
serait de revenir sur des propos qui
étaient visiblement
excessif les maires ne traite pas les
ministres des responsables d'une
question de respect c'est aussi quelque
chose qui doit exister dans ce pays et
respect qu'il n'existe pas dans les
propos de ces ministres pour le reste
moi j'ai surtout l'impression qu'on est
en quelque sorte sur on est dans le
monde des shadoks on interdit les livres
on interdit les fleurs les commerçants
indépendants de proximité se plaignent
et c'est normal la représentante de la
ceppm du xiii a expliqué qu'il n'y avait
pas de risque sanitaire avéré qu'il ya
des mesures sanitaires prises
individuellement dans ses magasins et
plutôt que de les autoriser à pouvoir
faire leur travail
on interdit aux grandes surfaces de le
faire si on ne laisse comme seule
solution aux français qui ont besoin de
pouvoir consommer de pouvoir vivre de
pouvoir préparer les fêtes de fin
d'année que d'aller vers les gaffes à
d'aller vers amazon
je crois qu'on est sur quelque chose
d'absolument fou ce gouvernement sur ce
sujet réagi comme souvent depuis le mois
de mars en retard comme une région
retard ils sur-réagissent il se rend
compte qu'ils surent réagir mais ils
refusent d'amendé complètement une
sur-réaction pour ne pas perdre la face
moi je crois profondément que dans la
vie en politique également une erreur ça
peut arriver notamment quand on agit
sous la pression quand on agit dans
l'urgence quand on fait face à des
crises mais l'honneur du politique c'est
de savoir revenir sur une erreur c'est
de savoir reconnaître quand il ya une
erreur qu'on a poussé le curseur un
petit peu trop loin qu'il faut revenir
en arrière et tous ces maires moi j'ai
choisi de ne pas prendre d'arrêté parce
que ces arrêtés sont illégaux seront
systématiquement cassés mais avec
l'association des maires d'ile-de-france
nous allons attaquer le décret du
gouvernement mais faut bien avoir
conscience que tous ces maires sont tout
sauf des irresponsables tous ces maires
propose des solutions propose d'être les
garants pour permettre à nos commerçants
de continuer à vivre ce qu'on est en
train de faire aujourd'hui c'est de
créer une injustice absolument folle ses
deux duels commerciaux même pas le
commerce de proximité par le petit
commerce le commerce physique tout
simplement au profil de gaza qui ne crée
quasiment pas dans notre pays qui paye
extrêmement peu d'impôts et
vraiment moi je pense que le mauvais
combat le mauvais débat ça a été encore
une fois d'essayer de qui vais essayer
d'opposer petits commerces et grandes
surfaces on va dire qu'il ya des grandes
surfaces qui ont eu des gestes de
solidarité extrêmement fort par rapport
aux commerçants de leur commune et je
crois qu'on est sur quelque chose on ne
doit pas être divisée
on doit être rassemblé que le rôle du
gouvernement c'est pas d'avoir des
propos exagérés vis-à-vis des mères
c'est pas de traiter ceux qui sont en
désaccord avec lui dit responsable
c'est effectivement d'essayer d'écouté
d'essayer de travailler ensemble et
d'essayer dans un contexte extrêmement
compliqué et bien tout simplement
pouvoir essayer de protéger l'essentiel
et moi je ne comprends pas comment on
peut nous expliquer aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a pas de risque à aller travailler
mais qu'on peut pas aller chez son
coiffeur qu' il n'y a pas de risque à
pouvoir aller chez un sophrologue mais
que dans le même temps on peut pas aller
acheter des fleurs
on voit bien le niveau des cohérences
qu'il y a on a un café tabac qui pourra
ouvrir alors qu'un café tout seul ne
peut pas ouvrir enfin on est sur quelque
chose qui est profondément irrationnelle
on voit dans le cadre des auto écoles où
les cours ne peuvent pas être dispensés
mais pour autant on peut faire passer
les examens
enfin on a toute une série d'adaptations
à voir le gouvernement aujourd'hui se
retrancher se cache derrière une date
fixée à quinze jours par le président de
la république
le problème c'est pas à quinze jours
c'est aujourd'hui on a des indépendants
qui sont en train de voir leur activité
mourir et ça c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas supportable et il
ya une urgence
on ne peut pas attendre 15 jours et je
pense que l'honneur du gouvernement
et bien c'est tout simplement de
s'adapter personne n'a la solution exact
personne n'a la science infuse
on fait face à une crise sans précédent
chacun la découvre petit à petit essaye
de s'adapter mais en général je crois
que l'intelligence collective elle est
plus forte que ce qui se fait à trois ou
quatre dans un cabinet ministériel
alors à vos côtés avec six poulains
qu'on connaît bien sûr rt france vous
intervenez dans un instant juste juste
avant je me tourne vers vous corinne et
nestea seul à magasins sur trois un site
internet a regretté le
de l'économie bruno le maire un fonds de
100 millions d'euros pour digitaliser
les petits commerces va être débloquée
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement il faut
que les commerces de proximité sans part
d'internet pour exister selon vous est
ce que c'est une piste jouable ou alors
il n'y a qu'une seule arte à une seule
alternative finalement ouvrir tous les
commerces au plus vite dès le 13
novembre quand comme le demande des
commerçants alors le n'empêche pas
l'autre bien évidemment nous la demande
c'est que les commerces soient ouverts
le plus vite possible
je remercie d'ailleurs les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus et qui vont
justement dans le sens de ce que nous
pensons par contre vous avez révélé et
la crise de son duc au vide a bien
révélé que les commerçants n'étaient pas
assez bien équipé en digitalisation et
c'est vrai que c'est sommes pas à
franchir
donc beaucoup de plateformes sont
comment ça a été de développer nous
mêmes la ceppm 13 nous avons mis en
place
on y travaille depuis deux ans et
justement grâce à l'accélération on a pu
avoir des financements complémentaires
et on le propose à l'ensemble des
commerçants de mai des plates formes en
ligne pour ceux qui ne sont pas déjà
équipés la région bien la région de paca
sud vient également de de confirmer
qu'elle met en place une plate forme
donc tout le monde les acteurs
économiques les acteurs locaux se sont
emparés bien évidemment de la solution
absolument nécessaire qui est le mettre
en place est digitalisation mais ça
n'empêche pas je le répète que nous
demandons l'ouverture le plus vite
possible surtout dans cette période
parce que qu'est ce qui va se passer
et bien si on ouvre le plus tard plus
vite on ouvrira et moi les effets de la
perte de chiffre d'affaires seront
ressentis parce que les aides c'est
toujours pareil on nous annonce des
aides
je vous avais je vous rappelle encore
une fois que les décrets annoncé surtout
à marseille nous avons connu en
septembre la fermeture la dernière
semaine de septembre fermeture des bars
restaurants les fonds sociaux le fonds
social de solidarité à 10000 euros n'est
toujours pas actée personne ne l'a
aperçu car les décrets ne sont toujours
pas parus donc faut bien comprendre
aussi cette détresse financière qui fait
que non seulement tout le monde
dans un souci de civisme citoyenneté à
respecter
on lui a demandé de respecter mais pour
autant les aides ne sont pas là et les
indes elles doivent aller au delà de la
simple subventions il va falloir
indemniser vraiment le préjudice pour
ces entreprises parce que les petits
commerçants sont tous des indépendants
et vous savez que quand vos salariés
sont ni l'activité
heureusement d'ailleurs l'état a mis en
place le chômage partiel
il n'y a absolument rien pour le chef
d'entreprise ni rémunération partiel à
l'heure actuelle ni même si
malheureusement et comme nous le
craignons beaucoup de commerçants
d'entreprises vont sans doute déposé le
bilan et on le souhaite bien sûr le plus
tard possible
ils n'auront pas de chômage pas
d'allocation pas d'indemnisation
ils devront même supporter les charges
sociales car ils seront non pas une
dette de l'entreprise mais une dette
personnelle
donc tout est assez dramatique et plus
vite le gouvernement autorisera
l'ouverture des commerces et si possible
maintenant le 13 novembre mieux se fera
et en plus bon mais je le répète si la
crise permet aux commerçants de passer
une étape qui va leur permettre de
vendre un peu plus en ligne
sachant que bon la digitalisation ces
10% 1 quand même aujourd'hui à gauche
pas tous présentera demain c'est pas non
plus le plus gros de chiffre d'affaires
aujourd'hui on a besoin de lien social
nos petits commerçants pourquoi ils sont
si importants parce que c'est avant tout
des valeurs humaines s'il ya un lien
social
effectivement alexis poule a on vient
d'entendre donc amer une commerçante on
a entendu la détresse la colère et puis
d'un autre côté bien il est à cette
crise sanitaire ou au début de ce
journal on disait que les entendait les
chiffres un nouveau nouveau record selon
vous quel équilibre doit entendre le
gouvernement aujourd'hui le gouvernement
doit revenir à la raison
on est en train de vivre une folie
imposé par des technocrates qui sont en
train de faire la guerre au commerce
plutôt que de faire la guerre aux virus
si on était un tant soit peu sérieux le
confinement serait un confinement global
généralisée d'une quinzaine de jours où
les écoles également serait fermée où
tous très fermé là on a l'impression que
c'est les commerces qui sont punis tout
simplement et que le reste de la vie
doit continuer tant bien que mal avec le
télétravail d'un côté mais avec tous ces
écoliers tous ces professeurs tous ces
personnels administratifs qui doivent
assurer la continuité pédagogique qui ne
pouvait être assurée autrement puisque
le plan c'est la digitalisation le plan
de davos du forum économique mondial
c'est ce grétry 7,1 pour pousser les
gens à davantage de services en ligne et
numérique
pourquoi on ne met pas le paquet sur une
école justement qui permettrait ces
moments de confinement nécessaires pour
lutter contre le virus et éviter que les
soignants ne soit submergée à nouveau
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens parce
qu on leur enlevait la capacité à réagir
à des crises de cette ampleur là donc
aujourd'hui on paye tout simplement
l'incurie des gouvernements successifs
et emmanuel macron hérite cette incurie
mais que fait-il plutôt que de réagir
avec bon sens bien il réagi dans une
folie technocratique où on est en train
de regarder produit par produit ce qui
doit être interdits de vente dans les
grandes surfaces
parce que c'est la concurrence libre et
non faussée qui prévoit qui prévaut et
que les petits commerces eux sont
pénalisés mais c'est scandaleux c'est
proprement incompréhensible pour le
commun des mortels pour les commerçants
comme ça a été dit ceux là n'ont aucun
filet de sécurité
et ça a été dit par les ministres ce ne
sera pas tous les mois que le
gouvernement va trouver 15 milliards
pour soi-disant faire l'aumône et des
ses commerces qu'ils sont en train de
plomber volontairement par cette
politique de fou et encore une fois
de quelle confinement parle-t-on
j'apprends aujourd'hui par exemple que
les hospices de beaune vont organiser la
vente physiquement des grands crus le 15
novembre
250 personnes dans un lieu clos les
hospices de beaune
certes c'est un grand moment de culture
c'est la côte d'or etc
mais où est la logique dans les mesures
qui sont proposés et à côté de ça vous
avez encore une fois l'interdiction de
rester statique dans les parcs et
jardins l'interdiction de se promener
dans les espaces naturels enfin on est
encore une fois en train de vie
un moment de folie collective et je
crois que les maires ont raison de
lutter pour sauver leur commerce pour
sauver leur centre-ville pour sauver la
vie tout simplement
je crois que les commerçants ont raison
et je les trouve très obéissants très
gentil parce que évidemment on n'a pas
le choix on doit on devra obéir obéir à
ses lois à ces mesures totalement folle
et est aujourd'hui la raison à semble
avoir déserté et le gouvernement et
l'opposition
j'attends et je pense que beaucoup
attendent des paroles fortes parce que
non seulement les syndicats de la grande
distribution les syndicats des
commerçants
mais maintenant c'est le rôle aussi des
élus de la nation que ce soit les
députés qu'ils fassent le boulot qu'il
représente le pape et qu'ils arrêtent
d'obéir aux techno aujourd'hui on veut
on n'a pas l'impression que le
gouvernement lutte contre un virus et
qu'il fait à peu près n'importe quoi
pour faire croire qu'ils luttent contre
un virus et qu'il ne soit pas jugé
responsable à la fin compte tenu des
chiffres des morts qui vont s'accumuler
mais si on avait été sérieux depuis mars
on aurait ouvert des lits on aurait
donné des moyens on aurait arrêté de
donner comme ordre à la rs de fermer des
lits sap a été le cas alors sur les
conséquences de cette crise je vous
propose d'écouter frédéric jeanjean
le secrétaire général de l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie il s'est exprimé hier sur
notre enquête on écoute et puis on
réagit à l'heure actuelle je tire la
sonnette d'alarmé parce que je pense que
d'ici quelques semaines nous allons nous
retrouver avec des émeutes de la faim en
france et je vais vous donner un exemple
très simple il ya quantité de magasins
autour de mon établissement où les
vendeurs et vendeuses travaillons un
fixe et ensuite une grosse part variable
là ce mois ci leurs commerces étaient
ouverts ils vont pouvoir toucher leur
salaire à la fin du mois de novembre
la part variable aura disparu et nous
allons nous trouver avec les chefs
d'entreprises tpe pme qui eux n'ont pas
le chômage partiel
ils n'ont pas de couverture on leur a
proposé 1500 euros transformable en dix
mille euros
il faut voir la paperasse quêtes à
remplir il faut voir les délais nous ça
fait six semaines qu'on nous a promis
tout un tas dead à marseille
quand monsieur
vers ans et monsieur grisé était venu
monsieur castex a dit il ya une semaine
de ça lundi matin ce sera fait mardi au
plus tard
on attend toujours les décrets monsieur
le maire des émeutes de la faim
à l'avenir c'est une perspective que
vous craignez vous aussi des émeutes je
ne sais pas mais je crois qu'on peut
avoir un phénomène de refus un phénomène
quasi insurrectionnelle ou type gilet
jaune puissance 5 10 15
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
façonné le pays occidental dont le taux
de confiance dans son gouvernement sur
la gestion du comider le plus faible
on est sur un pays dont le taux de
confiance la cote de popularité du
président du premier ministre du
gouvernement est l'un des plus faibles
on est dans un pays où il n'y a plus de
contre-pouvoirs institutionnels vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure concernant le
parlement mais les grands pouvoirs ainsi
les gros contre pouvoirs institutionnels
n'existe quasiment plus dans notre pays
est aujourd'hui on sent monter une forme
de colère et je crois que sur ce point
des commerçants c'est vraiment une
erreur politique majeure majeur qui a
été fait parce que c'est ressenti comme
une injustice et incompris et pour être
respectées ou pour pouvoir être toléré
quand il n'est pas populaire
un gouvernement un pouvoir eh bien il
doit minima ne pas paraître injuste et
là il ya un sentiment d'injustice qui
est extrêmement fort et qui est en train
de se créer et c'est pour ça que je
pense qu' il serait important pour le
gouvernement mais pour notre pays de
revenir là dessus
ensuite je vous disais moi vraiment au
sens samedi matin j'étais dans ma
commune j'étais au marché je faisais le
tour des commerçants qui pour ceux qui
pouvaient encore être ouvert
j'ai vu énormément de d'habitants qui me
parlait de cette peur qui me parlait de
cette colère qui gronde et aujourd'hui
on sent bien qu'ils aient un phénomène
qui calme cette colère une espèce de
la 2e
couvercle sur la marmite c'est la peur
parce qu'il ya une peur global qui est
logique de la pandémie du risque de la
maladie pour soi pour ses proches pour
les autres je suis extrêmement inquiet
de ce qui va arriver dans quatre cinq
six mois quand on sera en mars avril mai
qu'on sera je l'espère sortie de cette
pandémie que notre pays comme beaucoup
d'autres contrats ces morts que notre
pays comme beaucoup d'autres cherchera
des responsabilités et qu'on aura des
centaines de milliers de français qui
vivront un déclassement social parce que
le chômage partiel viable un moment
offert le payer les entreprises qui vont
fermer qui vont baisser le rideau
il va bien falloir l'assumer et moi ce
qui me terrifie
c'est la potentialité d'une réaction
violente au printemps quand on sera
sorti de la crise sanitaire d'une france
massivement des classes et qui aura
perdu toute confiance en ses élites et
sur des choses qui relève du symbole de
la capacité d'acceptation d'un pouvoir
qui relève du sentiment de justice ou
d'injustice
je crois vraiment qu'il faut que le
gouvernement entende entende sa
population entendent les élus qui ne
sont au fond que la voix des territoires
et à face très très vite machine arrière
sur ce sujet en mettant toutes les
conditions sanitaires s'il faut durcir
les protocoles les commerces eux sont
prêts à le faire les maires centre est
en net et garant sont prêts à s'investir
davantage la question n'est pas d'être
irresponsable de dire y'a pas de risques
et que de lire le covan ne tue pas mais
on est dans une situation où je pense
que le corps social français n'est pas
n'est plus en état de subir quelque
chose qu'il considérait une injustice
surtout quand ils voient pas les
résultats
merci à tous les trois d'avoir échangé
en direct ce soir sur notre antenne
merci à vous corinne in est-il
présidente ces pme très c'est la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises merci à vous jean philippe
dugoin clément mais rudy de même si vice
président région ile de france en charge
environnementale et merci à vous alexis
poulain éditorialistes rester avec nous
sur rt france dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la présidentielle
américaine direction washington où nous
notre envoyé spécial stéphanie de murs
rue à la veille d'un scrutin dont
l'issue est plus que jamais incertaine
puis nous parlerons du soutien des
émirats arabes unis à emmanuel macron
après ses propos sur la liberté
d'expression
alors que la colère du monde musulman
reste vive comme au bangladesh a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et la préparer il
ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire en traîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter vert à 30% de son
pipe pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux il
ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme s'est pas toute
fiabilité du projet ne serait ce qu'au
business et on oscille entre 92 et 98 5%
ça fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sont les coûts actuels
du pcr on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait aux peut-être
faire en sorte qu'on fasse appel à un
savoir faire savoir faire médical aussi
dans un domaine un peu différente et
celui de l'animal mais après tout
l'homme c'est un animal complot
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu' ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française et direction les états unis
tout de suite à la veille de l'élection
présidentielle nous retrouvons un autre
envoyé spécial à washington stéphanie de
méru
[Musique]
stéphanie bonjour très heureux de vous
retrouver depuis washington alors j -
avant l'élection dernière ligne droite
pour les deux candidats et c'est
évidemment le marathon pour recueillir
les derniers votes des électeurs
bonjour olivier évidemment un vrai
marathon vous vous en doutez commençons
par donald trump il enchaîne aujourd'hui
pas moins de cinq meetings dans quatre
états différents caroline du nord
pennsylvanie michigan wisconsin avec un
dernier stop grogne rapids au michigan
c'est là bas précisément qu'il avait
créé la surprise en 2016 en raflant ce
fief traditionnellement acquis aux
démocrates tous ses états en tout cas
ont un point commun celui d'être des
états clés ces fameux swing states dans
lequel se joue véritablement l'élection
joba et d'un lui aussi se concentre bien
évidemment sur ses états clés est sans
doute le plus important d'entre eux avec
la floride jdir et la pennsylvanie où il
est d'ailleurs née joe biden celui qui
l'emportent dans cet état de
pennsylvanie gagne 20 grands électeurs
c'est la pennsylvanie qui avait fait
basculer l'élection en 2016 la
pennsylvanie d'ailleurs qui a élu 20 des
25 5 derniers présidents américains
c'est vous dire à quel point cet état
est majeur et joe biden en a bien
conscience écouter le lors d'un meeting
justement hier en pennsylvanie chaque
jour chaque jour est un nouveau rappel
de l'importance des enjeux
jusqu'où ira l'autre camp pour tenter de
supprimer la participation surtout ici à
philadelphie le président trump a très
peur de ce qui va se passer en
pennsylvanie il sait que les habitants
de pennsylvanie ont leur mot à dire
si vous avez votre mot à dire il sait
qu'il n'a aucune chance
mais pourquoi est ce si important
justement la pennsylvanie et bien on l'a
entendu un joe biden en direct de
philadelphie il ya aussi pittsburgh qui
est très acquis aux démocrates mais
l'état est tout de même assez divisés
puisque le reste de l'état de
pennsylvanie est plutôt rurale et blanc
si j'ose dire donc d'où l'importance
caille que joe biden à y rechercher des
voies là-bas joe biden qui a pu compter
aujourd'hui également sur le soutien de
barack obama en meeting pour joe biden
en géorgie et en floride
autre état clé majeure puisque celui qui
l'emportera là-bas remportera 29 grands
électeurs au lycée alors stéphanie sous
nous sommes donc à la veille de
l'élection et il y a plus de doute sur
le fait qu'on puisse connaître le nom du
vainqueur dès le 4 novembre au matin
il ya de plus en plus de doutes en rien
n'est moins sûr pour annoncer le
vainqueur il faut être en mesure de
savoir si l'un des candidats atteint
vous savez la barre des 2 170 grands
électeurs sur 538 grands électeurs mais
la pandémie là aussi est venu
bouleverser cette élection puisque
les électeurs ont été exhortées à
utiliser le vote anticipé et le vote par
correspondance ici bat des records je
vais vous donner quelques chiffres les
derniers plus de 95 millions 500 mille
américains ont déjà voté pour cette
élection présidentielle qui se tiendra
demain dont 62 millions 200 mille peu
juste par correspondance c'est
l'équivalent de 70 % de la totalité des
votes de 2016
sauf que chaque état a ses règles pour
dépouiller en ces fameux bulletin de
bulletins de vote certains ont déjà
commencé d'autres comme justement la
fameuse pennsylvanie où le wisconsin
vont le faire le jour j ça veut dire que
ça peut prendre du temps bien évidemment
on s'en doute ce qui crée l'inquiétude
des observateurs mais et surtout aussi
du camp républicain qui voit là une
manière de faire des fraudes écouter
donald trump qui a mis en garde
je pense que c'est terrible quand les
butins ne peuvent pas être collectées
après une élection
je pense que c'est terrible quand des
personnes ou des états peuvent prendre
beaucoup de temps après que les
élections soient terminés pour compiler
les votes parce que ça ne peut mener
qu'à une chose et c'est très mauvais
vous savez à quoi ça peut mener
je pense que c'est une chose très
dangereuse terrible je pense qu'il
pourrait y avoir beaucoup de fraude et
d'abus
je pense que la cour suprême a pris
terrible décision une terrible décision
mais je ne sais pas si ça va changer
parce qu'on va arriver à la nuit dès que
les élections sont finies
nous avocats entrent en jeu
et on comprend en écoutant de notre
homme c'est justement là que le bât
blesse si les résultats sont serrés
notamment toujours dans cette fameuse
pennsylvanie où par exemple dans le
michigan et bien le camp républicain
déjà dense et déjà annoncé qu'ils
allaient contester en justice
cette élection et demandé le recomptage
des voix s'étaient déjà arrivé je ne
sais pas si vous vous en souvenez à
l'époque c'était à l'époque de al gore
et bush en floride
finalement al gore avait décidé de ne
pas contester et george bush avait ainsi
remporté la présidentielle d'à peine
quelques centaines de voix d'écart merci
beaucoup stéphanie pour toutes ces
précisions merci de nous faire vivre au
plus près du terrain cette campagne et
on se retrouve demain pour le jour j
avec une édition spéciale avant les
résultats à suivre en direct sur rt
france et puis depuis plusieurs semaines
la crispation des débats entre les deux
camps montrent avec parfois des scènes
de violence alors au pays de la liberté
d'expression peut-on encore soutenir son
candidat en toute sérénité
reportage outre-atlantique signé thomas
bonnin dans les rues de new york vous
aurez du mal à trouver des supporters de
donald trump ou en tout cas des
personnes qui se revendique en tant que
tel il ya bien des gens qui arborent des
autocollants à l'effigié de john dryden
par exemple mais personne ne porte cette
fameuse casquette rouge mec america and
white guen un des symboles de ralliement
des supporters de donald trump et
lorsque certains osent cet accoutrement
dans les rues de la ville il peut leur
arriver quelques problèmes c'est en tout
cas l'histoire qui est arrivé à cet
homme dans les rues new york il ya
maintenant plusieurs semaines
un homme affirme avoir été frappée à new
york parce qu'il portait une casquette
michael meurer cas great games il ya
moins de dix jours des supporters de
donald trump se sont donné rendez vous à
quelques mètres d'ici à times square et
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés ils ont
rapidement été rejoints par des
contre-manifestants ce qui a provoqué
des violences affrontements en plein
coeur de la ville
[Applaudissements]
ap
d'où cette question est ce qu'il est
dangereux aujourd'hui à new york de
porter un symbole de ralliement à donald
trump
on a posé la question un certain nombre
de new york m il ne faut pas faire ça ce
serait chercher le conflit cherché la
confrontation
franchement je ne le conseille pas
surtout vu le cuma s'est amusé on n'est
jamais trop prudent et des gens francs
des gens honnêtes il dit ce qu'on a sur
le coeur donc ce genre de chose ne me
surprend pas je leur demanderai d'abord
pourquoi ils soutiennent trump
c'est un homme qui distille la haine
comme vous le savez ce supermarché n'en
a pas l'air mais il illustre à lui seul
les tensions qui peuvent exister entre
les électeurs du camp byden éduquant
trump il ya quelques jours le gérant de
ce magasin on est à l'ong island à une
centaine de kilomètres de manhattan à
proposer à ses clients une remise de 20%
mais une remise qui ne s'applique
uniquement pour les supporters de donald
trump lorsqu'il a publié cette annonce
sur les réseaux sociaux de son
établissement
l'énervement de réactions notamment de
la part de certains démocrates qui ont
appelé au boycott de ce supermarché on a
été boycottée par la gauche n'achetez
pas ici etc
mais on a aussi des partisans de trump
qui sont venus nous soutenir
ils ne sont même pas venus pour les
promotions mais juste pour nous apporter
leur soutien nous sommes dans un pays
libre
il s'agit de ma liberté d'expression et
personne ne me privera de ce droit face
à tant de réactions
le propriétaire a donc décidé
d'appliquer cette réduction également
pour ceux qui se revendiquent comme des
supporters de joe byden alors qu'en
pensent les clients ou encore les
propriétaires des autres établissements
qui se trouve à côté on était leur poser
la question personnellement nous moi je
n'aurais pas fait ça je gère mon magasin
tout le monde a ses propres convictions
ses propres opinions politiques
je n'aurais pas fait ça il veut soutenir
trump et pourquoi pas les grosses
entreprises donnent de l'argent aux
candidats
pourquoi n'aurait-il pas le droit il
faut bien voter pour quelqu'un
je ne vois pas le problème il est donc
devenu très difficile d'afficher sa
préférence sans risquer un retour de
bâton et il ne s'agit pas uniquement des
supporters de donald trump
cette femme s'est également retrouvée
sous le feu des critiques pour avoir
réalisé cette vidéo sur tik tok voile
affirme seulement que son père
républicain de toujours a décidé de
voter pour joe biden cette année afin de
faire plaisir à ses filles
un message qui se voulait inspirant et
qui a finalement provoqué beaucoup de
réactions agressives
finalement ces exemples illustrent à
quel point les clivages sont désormais
ancré dans la population américaine peu
importe qui remportera le scrutin cette
année il y aura de toute façon plusieurs
paires dans le dialogue et la tolérance
dans les débats politiques par exemple
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
eric branaa maître de conférences à
l'université paris ii assas spécialiste
des états unis auteur du livre joe biden
une biographie qui vient d'être publié
aux éditions du nouveau monde jean eric
branaa merci d'être en direct avec nos
cieux restez france alors on a vu dans
le sujet et il ya quelques secondes les
tensions que suscite cette cette
campagne est ce que la crainte de
violence est réelle dans les heures les
jours à venir selon vous je crois quand
même qu'elle est nettement exagéré qui
pullulent visite aux etats-unis marque
depuis quatre ans maintenant les deux
rives démocrate et républicaine se sont
éloignées l'une de l'autre il ya un vrai
gouffre entre les deux sabots quotidien
les gens ne se parlent plus 6on d'une
pinho une autre il y a deux vérité
alternative pour chaque information
quasiment on a le côté pile et le côté
face avec des vérités très différente
tout ça est une réalité aujourd'hui aux
états unis et les tensions extrêmes ne
sont même à la limite confrontation elle
votre reportage l'expliqué de façon
assez éclatante mais on pourrait
continuer en expliquant qu'il ya eu un
mort accueillent aux chalets notera
propre à portland pour signaler des
morts des deux côtés
c'est vrai que tout cela inquiète mais
en même temps l'élection est un autre
temps et après l'érection
on peut en tout cas douter qu'il y aura
le catastrophisme que certains annoncent
un petit peu sur tous les temps avec des
mini ce méli ce qui descendraient dans
la rue ça fait partie de cette histoire
des élections américaines où on en
entend réguler on parle là des fois
qu'il ya eu des risques de milice était
en l'an 1800 c'était l'élection de
thomas jefferson et c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là les tensions étaient
absolument extrême avec des vrais
milices pour le coup puisque elle venait
d'être créé armé qui patrouillaient dans
les rues et qui se confronter les uns
aux autres je doute qu'on en soit là
cette fois ci même s'il peut y avoir un
débordement à droite à gauche parce que
des gens déséquilibre il y en a partout
alors vous avez publié une fois une
biographie on le disait de joe biden
alors est ce que c'est un vrai favori
est ce qu il a les ressorts suffisant
pour faire perdre
trump et lui succéder alors absolument
mais dans un premier temps c'est comme
ça qu'est rentrer en campagne il est
rentré dans l'idée qu'il fallait faire
un référendum en titrant que ça tombait
bien que donald trump voulait aussi
faire un référendum trop train pour le
coup donc ils étaient au moins d'accord
sur ce point là et c'est vrai que le joe
biden s'est inscrit dans un premier
temps dans l'héritage de barack obama
dont qu'il comptait capitaliser sur la
très bonne image de de celui qu'il avait
servi comme président donald ram fait
quasiment 90% chez ses supporteurs et
obama à cathode quasiment la même chose
chez les démocrates donc on avait une
lutte équilibré bayh dole essayant de
récupérer les dividendes
et puis la pandémie est passée par là
c'est le deuxième temps aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens votent pour avoir un
président consolateur réparateur qui va
s'occuper d'eux parce qu'il y a des
vrais problèmes de santé des économies
d'emploi et en plus des problèmes
sociaux qui s'ajouté donc ils cherchent
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus rassurant et
d'apaiser que donald trump et dans un
troisième écran c'est vrai que le
programme qui a été construit par joe
biden à la suite de l'abandon dans la
course de bernie sanders construit
d'ailleurs
avec les progressistes puisque il avait
créé huit commissions de travail
coprésidé par un progressiste un modéré
on finit par séduire même le camp pro
des sites il a donc réuni le camp
démocrate qui lui a permis comme il le
fait depuis 47 ans aux politiques de se
tourner vers l'autre camp c'est un homme
de compromis
il s'est donc tourné vers républicain
c'était le plus républicain compatible
des démocrates et il a donc pu continuer
sa construction en donnant cette fois ci
au camp plus républicain ce qui rassure
même d'ailleurs dans les contrats piste
on entend régulièrement certaines
personnes qui disent qu ils donnent
après tout c'est le moins pire de tout
c'est que avec lui sera possible de
fonctionner alors arrêtons nous quelques
instants sur les swing states pourquoi
ces départs vont déterminer le résultat
du scrutin
alors est ce qu'on appelle des twins
taille des tapis vaut deux et en
balançant d'irak en gros ce sont des
résumés des états qui sont très partagés
entre démocrates et républicains donc ça
penche au coût d'un côté un coup de
l'autre et la particularité cette année
c'est que les 12 états pivots ont tous
été gagné par donald trump en 2016 donc
la pression elle est ce ses épaules il
faut qu'ils aient regagne quasiment tous
en tout cas eux jusqu'au gain qui l'a vu
la dernière fois c'est à dire une avance
de 38 grands électeurs et justement
cette avance est tellement plus que pour
le maiden partie est assez facile en
regagnant le risque a noté dans le
michigan où il est donné très largement
en avance il suffit de gagner un sale
état et il est président des états unis
alors si l'on gagne 2 3 4 ce sera donc
une avance qui s'ajoutera c'est pour ça
qu'il est super favori aujourd'hui cette
élection est serré les résultats du
scrutin
il ya des chances pour qu'il soit a
contesté par donald trump
c'est ce qu'il nous dit mais ça fait
partie aussi du discours politique un
peu classique d'abord donald 3 nous
avait dit la même chose en 2016 qu'il
contesterait qu'il avait des fraudes il
avait annoncé depuis très longtemps en
intensifiant aka
jour du scrutin sur cette thématique il
annoncé aussi que ces supporters
descendrait dans les rues tout cela il
n'y a rien de nouveau de ce côté là
maintenant est-ce qu'il contestera
d'abord c'est pas dans la tradition
américaine il ya eu des élections très
compliqué en 1800 en 1804 ans en 1876 et
puis en 1967 de kennedy ou plus près de
nous celle de demi cela est expliqué
dans un reportage tout à l'heure mais à
chaque fois le candidat qui est en face
fini par concéder la victoire et tout
rentre dans l'ordre
est-ce que donald trump ira jusqu'au
bout de la contestation c'est à dire
d'amener cela dans les différentes cours
d etat puis ensuite en cour suprême puis
ensuite de contester le résultat des
grands électeurs pour que le congrès se
saisisse de cette affaire mais je suis
crois pas beaucoup parce que ce serait
pas une sortie honorable sachant que à
la fin joe biden si les les sondages le
confirment aura quand même une avance
assez confortable
merci beaucoup jean eric branaa je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université paris ii
assas spécialiste des états unis et
auteur du livre joe biden une biographie
qui vient d'être publié aux éditions du
nouveau monde
[Musique]
et l'actualité de ce lundi a aussi été
marquée en france par une minute de
silence observée par les élèves pour
rendre hommage à samuel pâtit assassiné
pour avoir montré des caricatures du
prophète mahomet à ses élèves
et pendant ce temps là des
manifestations d'ampleur ont eu lieu au
bangladesh et à jakarta contre la france
et emmanuel macron elle des
rassemblements qui appellent au boycott
des produits français et qui condamne
les propos du président de la république
sur la liberté de caricaturé le prophète
retour sur ces manifestations avec
florian lambert des images qui parlent
d'elles mêmes mais qui se multiplient
ces derniers jours dans certains états
musulmans depuis près d'une semaine
plusieurs pays ont manifesté contre la
france et emmanuel macron après ses
propos sur la liberté d'expression et le
droit de caricaturé le prophète mahomet
[Musique]
à dacca au bangladesh
comme à jakarta en indonésie des
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées ce lundi dans un climat
hostile les participants ont scandé des
slogans appelant au boycott de
marchandises françaises
nous avons boycotter des produits
l'oréal paris et tous les produits de
paris ou de france que nous avons à
cause de ce qu'ils font et de ce qu'ils
ont dit sur notre prophète alors nous
boycottons ses produits pour pouvoir
leur montrer notre pouvoir
des manifestations qui se multiplient
dans les pays musulmans et qui inquiète
la france endeuillée à plusieurs
reprises par plusieurs attentats
islamistes ces derniers jours face à
cette défiance
plusieurs fédérations nationales
musulmane et grande mosquée condamne je
cite les appels injustifiés au boycott
des produits français
notre condamnation des appels
injustifiés au boycott des produits
français
les médias de france est en libre aucun
responsable politique y compris le
président de la république française ne
peut imposer à un organe de presse
une publication ou une non publication
d'un dessin ou d'une caricature aussi
nous considérons que ces appels sont
infondées et reposent sur des
manipulations politiques
cachant d'autre objectif que la défense
de l'islam
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian a appelé
les ressortissants français vivant à
l'étranger à la prudence estimant je
cite que la menace contre les intérêts
français était partout
et pour en parler claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales nous
a rejoint claude blanchemaison bonsoir
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france ils vont soit alors concernant le
boycott des produits français ce qu'il y
a déjà eu des précédents
oui ça s'est déjà produit et peut-être
on planche cité deux exemples parce
qu'ils éclairent la situation actuelle
le premier c'est le boycott des produits
français aux états unis d'amérique en
2003 lorsque la france avait refusé de
participer à la deuxième guerre d'irak
et qu'elle avait dans un débat au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
pris position très clairement en disant
qu'il n'y avait pas de raison de faire
une nouvelle expédition en irak
alors on avait vu les américains
déverser des bouteilles de champagne
dans les caniveaux à new york
en effet le boycott a porté pendant
quelques semaines sur les produits
alimentaires les produits cosmétiques et
les produits de luxe mais ça n'a pas
duré très longtemps
le deuxième exemple eh bien c'est en
turquie
déjà en 2012 à l'époque monsieur le guen
était premier ministre et il voulait
empêcher le sénat français de voter la
loi qui faisait du déni de du déni du
génocide arménien à un crime au sens du
code pénal français bien entendu ça n'a
pas empêché le parlement français
d'adopter cette loi et le génocide
arménien le déni du génocide arménien
est devenu un crime au sens du droit
pénal et bien le boycott n'a pas eu
beaucoup de succès d'autant plus qu'à
l'époque un grand nombre de turcs se
sont aperçus que des produits français
bien les brebis français étaient
fabriquées en turquie il ya une usine
renault
il y à des produits
laitiers qui sont également fabriquées
en turquie et par conséquent cela
risquait de produits de produire du
chômage plus qu'autre chose alors
aujourd'hui il ya donc eu ce soutien des
émirats arabes unis à emmanuel macron à
ce que cela est surprenant
en tout cas moi j'ai envie de dire que
c'est très important que ces courageux
et que ça n'est pas très surprenant
alors c'est important parce que les
émirats arabes unis sont un pays qui
appartient au conseil de coopération du
golfe qu'il a de très bons rapports avec
l'arabie saoudite avec l'egypte c'est un
pays influent et que les capitales
d'abou dhabi de dubaï joue un rôle très
important dans au proche orient
par conséquent c'est une c'est une bonne
nouvelle je crois d'autant plus que le
ministre des affaires étrangères dans
son interview à die welt de ce matin dit
il faut écouter monsieur macron il faut
lire monsieur macron et monsieur mâcon
dit il n'est pas question d'un dijonnais
dans un ghetto les musulmans qu'il faut
au contraire les intégrer à la
communauté française et qu' il n'a rien
contre la religion musulmane
il veut simplement se battre contre les
extrémistes et contre les terroristes
voilà je pense que d'autres pays
reprendront cet argument c'est courageux
parce que le au proche-orient peu de
dirigeants ont tenu ce langage
ouvertement même si beaucoup le pensent
en au fond d'eux mêmes
et puis je pense que cela n'est pas très
surprenant parce que la france a de très
bons rapports très diversifié avec les
émirats arabes unis il ya une
coopération militaire il ya des bases
militaires
il ya une coopération en matière
d'énergie en matière de transports et
dans l'interculturel puisqu'après tout
est bien un louvre abou dhabi alors en
tout cas les manifestations au
bangladesh par exemple se poursuivre
l'entretien du président français sur al
jazeera cela n'a pas suffi à apaiser les
esprits
non alors vous avez raison il ya de
grands pays musulmans en asie vous avez
montré tout à l'heure la situation à la
donner
690 millions la vie 290 millions
d'habitants on aurait pu parler du
pakistan 190 millions d'habitants et
parler du bangladesh 80 90 millions
d'habitants et dans ces pays les
mouvements islamistes ont appelé à un
boycott et les gouvernements laissent
faire
le président pakistanais le premier
ministre pakistanais pardon à lui-même
encouragé au boycott des produits
français parce que ça les arrange sur un
plan de politique intérieure et sur le
plan des équilibres intérieurs donc
probablement ce mouvement va durer
pendant quelques quelques quelques
semaines mais je pense que le contre-feu
allumé par l'interview du président
macron à la chaîne al jazeera le relais
par le miz affaires étrangères des
émirats arabes unis va faire son effet
dans les autres pays merci beaucoup
claude blanche maison pour votre analyse
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales est resté avec
nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur ce premier
jour de la rentrée pour 12 millions
d'élèves avec un protocole sanitaire
renforcée face au co vide
si le gouvernement insiste sur la
nécessité pour les enfants de ne pas
perdre le fil de l'école la situation
épidémique
elle inquiète les enseignants alors
doit-on maintenir coûte que coûte les
écoles ouvertes et à quel prix
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face à
tout de suite dans un peu moins de cinq
minutes sur rt france
[Musique]
levitt a été le révélateur des monstres
aux pieds d'argile que nous sommes la
france et je l'éteins elle veut devenir
veut partout mais on n'a pas les moyens
ma critique des dames c'est que notre
continuant à nier l'évidence c'est à
dire mais continue à mentir sur la
réalité de notre pouvoir qui est devenu
comme perdant est ce que cette france-là
bouffer moins peur que celle que vous
avez décrite ce pacte à nos membres de
la france lors j'ai peur c'est 2 du ca
qui pourrait à donner il pourrait être
réservé à notre grand et beau pays
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pg les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas l'autre point
faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
certain chohada et tout le monde discute
et finalement tu mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois vous voyez des images
assez touchants de l'armée qui était
presque impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus sais pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
il ne va pas être violent mais on va
rester
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 2 novembre 2009 un protocole
sanitaire renforcée port du masque
obligatoire dès le cp et minute de
silence ce matin pour 12 millions
d'élèves dans les écoles pour rendre
hommage à l'enseignant assassiné sa mère
pattie une rentrée scolaire particulière
alors que le conseil scientifique prédit
un hiver avec plusieurs vagues de
coronavirus le gouvernement insiste sur
la nécessité pour les enfants de ne pas
perdre le fil de l'école alors que les
enseignants s'inquiètent alors doit-on
maintenir coûte que coûte à les écoles
ouvertes mais à quel prix ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face à l'avenir
flou pour la côte d'ivoire et la crainte
de heurts post électoraux 48 heures
après une élection présidentielle
controversée
l'opposition annonce qu'elle va former
un gouvernement de transition
les résultats devraient être annoncés
dans la soirée un scrutin émaillé de
violences avec plusieurs morts notamment
quatre décès dans un village près de
yamoussoukro la capitale administrative
[Musique]
et puis en algérie la réforme
constitutionnelle approuvée par
référendum mais avec une abstention
record le oui recueille 66 8% des
suffrages exprimés 1 mais seuls 23 7 %
des électeurs se sont déplacés dans les
bureaux de vote
ce taux de participation fragilise la
volonté gouvernementale de clore la page
de miracle c'est le mouvement de
contestation né il ya bientôt deux sens
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
apprend à l'instant une attaque
terroriste visant une synagogue serait
en cours dans la ville de vienne en
autriche
un bilan provisoire fait état d'un mort
et plusieurs blessés
un plus d'informations à venir dans nos
prochaines éditions
on fait le point sur les dernières sud
les derniers chiffres du coronavirus en
france santé publique france dénombre 50
2518 nouveaux cas de contamination kobe
dans 24heures nouveau record 418
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital ces
dernières 24 heures et 430 patients
admis en réanimation
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 20,6 pour cent et
pour revenir sur la situation sanitaire
dans le pays
nous sommes avec bertrand legrand
médecins généralistes bertrand le grand
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors docteur port du masque
distanciation social ces mesures sont
rentrés dans le quotidien des français
et pourtant nous sommes en pleine
seconde vague et d'autres suivront a
prévenu le conseil scientifique comment
est ce que vous le comprenez on comprend
en regardant les chiffres que cette
deuxième vague est manifestement
beaucoup plus haute que la première il
suffit de regarder la pente de cette
deuxième vague on voit bien qu'on est au
tout début au pied de cette deuxième
vague et c'est pas foncièrement étonnant
puisque depuis le mois de septembre nous
les médecins de ville alertons sur le
fait qu'il ya un énorme
demande de soins en matière de risques
qu vide et que donc bien évidemment ce
soin là va déferler maintenant sur
l'hôpital l'hôpital est déjà débordé il
lui reste six semaines d'augmentation
d'un de l'intensité des hospitalisations
à subir donc effectivement mes collègues
hospitaliers vous risquent de souffrir
énormément et vous aussi donc dans votre
cabinet vous voyez de plus en plus de
malades qui ont les symptômes finalement
dû coronavirus alors en fait moi je suis
arrivé au maximum de ce que je pouvais
faire donc je ne vois plus
l'augmentation je ne vois plus que la
stabilité de mes capacités soigner mes
patients je suis arrivé au maximum tout
ce qui est au dessus du maximum mais
malheureusement pas pris en charge
alors le conseil scientifique plutôt
pessimiste sur l'évolution de la clé
sanitaire c'est votre cas également
we are pessimiste c'est évident qu'on
n'est pas dans la partie de la première
vague où on pouvait espérer maîtriser le
ce qui nous arrive est dessus et
clairement là on a bien tous compris que
la deuxième vague n'est absolument pas
freinée par les mesures qui ont été
prises auparavant voire même elles ont
été amplifiées par le passage de la 14è
n'a la septaine car je vous le rappelle
relâcher des personnes contagieuses dans
le milieu professionnel et maintenance
ou de cette vague là va devoir à arrivé
avec les six semaines de retard à la
prise de décision et je vous rappelle
qu'on est toujours pas changé
cette 14ème enfin ce retour à la 14è
n'est toujours pas actée donc on a
énormément de retard par rapport aux
virus et il va falloir encore subir
pendant six semaines
alors on a vu ce matin notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux des vidéos
d'embouteillage en région parisienne
mais pas seulement on en a vu aussi à
rennes la vie professionnelle finalement
continue la vie scolaire aussi ce
confinement partiel il reste suffisant
néanmoins pour surmonter cette seconde
vague non on voit bien que le déni est
complet je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous il suffit de ressortir dans la
rue pour se rendre compte que
effectivement une ce confinement
n'est pas un confinement au sens propre
du terme et donc du coup son effet sera
forcément insuffisant mais je pense que
les français ne sont pas prêts à
entendre que la deuxième vague est bien
présente et qu'elle sera plus forte et
que nous d'eux allons devoir faire des
stries en réanimation c'est juste une
évidence c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
donc pourquoi ça sa mairie relais de
sames hassan ça sera sympa face à force
ça forcément ça va pas s'arrêter quoi
mais français sont pas prêts de
l'entendre et c'est ça veut dire pour
vous il faudrait finalement une bonne
fois pour toutes
re avoir un nouveau confinement total
ça serait ça la solution aujourd'hui la
tristesse c'est que malheureusement le
confinement c'est le constat de l'échec
aujourd'hui on en est au point où la
france et les français ne veulent pas
entendre ce constat de l'échec on est
dans un déni telle que même les chèques
qui est sous nos yeux ne paraît même pas
possible bien entendu avant le
confinement il aurait fallu bien
évidemment passer de la septaine à la
14ème bien évidemment il fallait
renforcer les mesures de protection en
milieu scolaire tout un tas de mesures
que l'on a pris il ya maintenant si
cette semaine qui ont été très mauvaise
et qu'il fallait corriger avant
d'arriver au confinement mais le retard
mis en place par le gouvernement pour
corriger ses erreurs et tels que
on est contraint de confiner alors que
ça on en est même plus les moyens ni les
capacités ni les moyens politiques ni
les moyens économiques est bien évident
alors il ya eu là la rentrée scolaire ce
matin est ce qu'on veut aux craintes des
clusters dans les écoles des foyers de
contamination parce qu'il ya encore
cette interrogation est ce que les
élèves sont contagieux ou pas il ya
toujours des débats requis qu'on entend
ici ou là quel est votre regard sur 700
francs très longtemps j'ai cru que les
enfants n'étaient pas vecteur de la
maladie parce que dans mon cabinet j'ai
envoyé très peu qui était en amont de la
contamination des adultes est donc de 2
sur ce fait là à la première vague
j'étais intimement persuadé que les
enfants étaient très peu contagieux
force est de constater aujourd'hui que
la réouverture des écoles à la manière
dont cet effet en septembre avec un déni
total puisque je vous rappelle qu'on a
refusé d'admettre que des clusters
étaient présents dans les écoles pour ne
pas les fermer
et donc ce déni malheureusement nous
prouve que les enfants sont bel et bien
contaminants en vis-à-vis de leurs
professeurs et inversement
et que donc dès 6 ans très clairement
les enfants sont contaminants c'est une
évidence aujourd'hui on peut pas on peut
pas nier cette évidence alors ses élèves
dès le cp un bailleur qui porte le
masque certains disent qu'il serait
nécessaire de continuer de le porter à
la maison est ce que c'est un sens à la
maison malheureusement alors je suis
tout à fait pour vous le dire puisque
moi-même je suis testé positif aux que
jd et que donc je ne peux plus
travailler dans mon cabinet mais je
travaille par télé à consultation bien
évidemment que le sort d'une famille est
le même et il est partagé pour tous il
est complètement ridicule de penser qu'
on ne contaminera passé proche
je sais bien que la sécurité sociale m'a
dit que si je faisais très attention je
ne comptais me n'aurai pas mes proches
mais en réalité c'est totalement faux
nous savons tous très bien que quelqu'un
qui tombe malade contaminera ses proches
si c'est des enfants il ya moins de
risques si c'est des personnes âgées
bien évidemment que le risque est majeur
alors vous qui est du coup en
télétravail
aujourd'hui est ce que finalement ça
fonctionne bien ces consultations
à distance est ce que ça peut permettre
finalement de résoudre les files
d'attentes chez le médecin ou à
l'hôpital d'avoir recours à ces
télétravail pour les médecins ou alors
il manque quelque chose
bon pour faire le même nombre d'actes il
me faut à peu près 30% à 40% de temps en
plus c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et
avec un risque qui est plus important
puisque je n'examine pas mes patients
donc non c'est vraiment un pis-aller
on s'en était parfaitement du compte
pendant la première vague et dès qu'on
pourra abandonner la téléconsultation je
serai ravi de pouvoir l'abandonner la
qualité de service fait à mes patients
et est absolument déplorable par rapport
à un examen clinique et correctement
mené donc je n'ai qu'une seule hâte de
pouvoir rpt que retouché mes patients et
les réexaminer
mais pour l'instant c'est
malheureusement pas dans le
bénéfice-risque poche
merci beaucoup au docteur bertrand
legrand bon rétablissement à vous en
tout cas je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste et à l'occasion de
cette rentrée des classes après les
vacances de la toussaint nous avons
interrogé les parents d'élèves sur le
port du masque obligatoire dès 6 ans une
mesure qui divise regarder on soit je
pense que ça changera pas grand chose le
retour à l'école et a été pris avec
énormément d'enthousiasmé
donc normalement ça devrait le faire moi
ça change rien parce que ma fille depuis
depuis la rentrée de septembre elles
portent le masque et elle a dix ans donc
ça change rien la seule chose que
j'aimerais c'est qu'effectivement il
nettoie plus les classes plus souvent
mais sinon oui nous ça ça change pas
grand chose pour mon enfant mais je
trouve que c'est une très bonne chose
mais que de porter les masques et ça
incite aussi les parents à bien porter
les masques
bon on a l'impression de payer un peu la
débâcle du gouvernement on va pas se
mentir pas de masque au début et c'est
une bonne chose des masques après faut
que ça soit opposé à tout le monde
maintenant les enfants de 6 ans doivent
porter des masques alors qu'il ya un
mois il veut emporter
trop compliqué trop de règles on sait
plus vraiment comment s'y retrouver
on s'est pas fondamentalement qui a
raison il ya des discours scientifique
qui diffère très très dur de s'y
retrouver très compliqué je pense que je
pense que la meilleure chose qui peut
arriver c'est que les enfants puissent
retourner à l'école c'est important on
est a déjà privé de quasiment deux mois
de cours pendant pendant le printemps
donc il était essentiel que les enfants
puissent revenir à l'école ensuite sur
les mesures bonne mauvaise le masque
palmes masques je sais pas je ne sais
pas qui a raison mais en tout cas il est
important que les enfants puissent se
retrouver puis se continuer à
s'instruire et effet salle principale
donc je trouve c'est une bonne mesure
d'avoir l'effet d'école ouverte et
d'abord renforcer le protocole sanitaire
même si le risque zéro on voit bien
n'existe pas
si le gouvernement voit davantage de
bénéfices pour les enfants dans le fait
de pouvoir aller à l'école que de risque
d'être contaminé d'autres s'inquiètent à
des syndicats d'enseignants ont déposé
un préavis de grève du 2 au 7 novembre
afin de dénoncer les risques du
protocole sanitaire mis en place dans
les établissements scolaires face au co
vide alors doit-on maintenir coûte que
coûte les écoles ouvertes mais à quel
prix
on en parle tout de suite avec arno
fabre professeur de lettres classiques
administrateur national du mouvement des
stylos rouges
bonjour arno fabre merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france
alors nos têtes blondes sont donc masqué
dès le cp désormais ils doivent
respecter entre autres les distanciation
social limité les rassemblements le
protocole sanitaire en vigueur
est ce qu'il permet une rentrée sereine
le gros souci pour le principal souci
sur cette rentrée c'est évidemment que
le ministère de l'éducation annonce un
protocole renforcé alors que dans les
faits rien n'a changé de la même manière
que à la rentrée de septembre
on nous expliquait que tout était mis en
place pour une rentrée en parfaite
sûreté sanitaire alors qu en fait à part
le masque alors on peut se dire c'est
beaucoup mais à part le masque rien n'a
changé qu'est-ce qui les effectifs sont
toujours appelant 30 35 au lycée souvent
entre dans les petites écoles en collège
on tourne entre 28 et 30 et parfois un
peu moins 24 25 ans rép
mais rien n'a changé la distanciation
social n'est pas possible dans les
couloirs que ça soit aussi tout
simplement à la cantine en descendant
des escaliers dans la cour de récréation
dans les cours de ps qui ne se font pas
masquer cette distanciation est
impossible et là on nous explique qu'il
ya un très grand changement que
véritablement ça y est le protocole a
été renforcée mais c'est complètement
faux
on y était tous ce matin le protocole
n'a pas été renforcé
sauf effectivement cette mesure qui
monte là quand même la gravité de la
situation le fait que l'on impose le
masque à des enfants de 6 ans moi je ne
suis pas là pour juger de cette mesure
je dis simplement que si on masque des
enfants de 6 ans
c'est bien que les enfants sont
contaminants et ça c'est la chose qu'on
nous refuse un qu'on refuse d'admettre
depuis maintenant plus de demandes il
aurait fallu repousser la rentrée
scolaire selon vous la rentrée après
après ses vacances là sans doute ou du
moins si la rentrée devait se faire
parce que effectivement il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui
j'entendais un père d'élève qui disait
il était important que les enfants
reprennent bien sûr il est important
aussi qu'une fellation
l'hommage à notre collègue samuel bâti
et qui a été lâchement assassinés à part
un acte terroriste
c'est important de revoir les élèves
c'est important de parler avec eux c'est
important aussi de replacer des choses
simples mais claire sur la laïcité la
liberté d'expression de marquer le coup
aussi de manière très forte par cette
minute de silence que vous illustrez si
bien donc c'est important de se revoir
aujourd'hui mais dans les établissements
dès la fin de la matinée
ça s'est mis à débrayer partout certains
collèges ont dû fermer dans le 92 dans
le 93
dans le 94 des lycées entier
actuellement
sont à l'arrêt ou quasiment à l'arrêt
demain il y a les lycéens qui rentre
dans la danse
et tant mieux parce qu'ils sont les
premiers concernés par des conditions
d'études extrêmement dégradée et surtout
des conditions sanitaires qui ne les
protège pas du tout et qui ne nous
protège pas non plus le tout le monde
est en danger en les élèves les
professeurs et malheureusement tous
leurs proches
l'afflux les familles des élèves les
familles des enseignants et de tous les
personnels de l'éducation secrétaire ash
surveillants personnel personnels de
direction un million deux cent mille
adultes qu'ils aient pas du tout protégé
un à arno fabre jean michel blanc terre
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
s'exprimait sur france inter ce matin je
le cite un ce qui compte c'est que les
enfants ne perdent pas le fils de
l'école aller à l'école n'est pas un
risque sanitaire excessifs par rapport
au reste de la vie la priorité est ce
que pour vous aussi c'est que les
enfants ne perdent pas le film de
l'école alors que la priorité soit sauf
les enfants ne perd pas des filles de
l'école continue à s'instruire et cetera
bien entendu c'est le rôle de l'école la
question est de savoir comment se
fait-il que les demis groupe que la
plupart des organisations syndicales et
que en l'occurrence les stylos rouges
nous réclamons depuis la fin j'en n'ai
pas été mis en place
le professeur le docteur le grand que
vous interrogiez à l'instant le disait
très bien c'était des mesures qui
devaient être mises en place il ya huit
ou neuf semaines
curieusement regarder les courbes
épidémique la rentrée les à la rentrée
dans toutes les écoles les collèges les
lycées les universités s'est faite entre
eux on va dire le 1er et le 15 septembre
si on compte aussi un les universités
curieusement les pic de contamination
ont explosé quinze jours à trois
semaines après et donc là on est
vraiment dans le résultat de quelque
chose qui malheureusement aussi était
annoncé comment peut-on agir de manière
aussi responsable c'est ça le problème
c'est à dire que bien entendu on pouvait
remettre en place une partie du
téléenseignement on pouvait aussi faire
une chose qui était simple qui
consistait tout simple
apprendre les élèves en demi groupe soit
une journée et l'autre l'autre demie
groupe l'autre journée ou même sur des
deux mi journée et les écoles notamment
pour les petits parce que pour les
lycéens ça pose pas vraiment de problème
s'ils ont une demi journée à travailler
chez eux bon peut-être que certains ne
travailleront pas beaucoup mais
globalement c'était faisable pour les
petits ça ça pose un vrai problème parce
que l'école a été transformé en garderie
donc à partir de là il fallait avec les
mairies se mettre en place mais tu que
qu'on met en place et bien un service
d'accueil comme ça peut se faire
d'ailleurs dans les grandes grèves et
c'était faisable et mairie ont des
locaux
elles ont des agents municipaux qui
pouvaient parfaitement s'occuper et bien
de ses enfants dans le temps au dans la
demi journée 2-3 heures par jour où il
n'aurait pas eu classe parce que
d'autres auraient été avec avec la
maîtresse alors le maître alors najad
najat gala scène vice présidente de la
fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves nous a rejoint sur rt france
najat belkacem bonsoir alors on vient
d'entendre arno fabre a insisté sur le
fait qu'effectivement le protocole
sanitaire n'avait pas été revu qu'il
aurait peut-être mieux fallu reporter
cette rentrée scolaire quel est votre
regard est ce que vous partagez
finalement ce constat de jean michel
blanquer à savoir ce qui compte c'est
que les enfants ne perdent pas le fils
de l'école oui alors c'est sûr que
l'école est importante pour tout le
monde que ce soit pour les élèves ou
pour les familles
par contre ça dépend dans quelle
condition aujourd'hui les élèves de
primaire sont rentrés dans des
conditions très compliquées avec un port
du masque dont ils n'ont pas l'habitude
et puis les collégiens et les lycéens
avant
avant cette rentrée on avait déjà
constaté des cas qu'ovide dans certaines
classes
donc on se pose la question de savoir
est ce que même le port du masque dans
ces conditions va diminuer la diffusion
du virus
ce qu'on avait proposé à la fcpe est ce
qu on a défendu pendant très longtemps
c'est d'alléger les classes en 2000
groupe de façon à ce que la
distanciation physique qu'on préconise
que préconisent les scientifiques
puissent se faire dans les meilleures
conditions
donc à ça ça n'a pas été entendu
aujourd'hui on leur demande pour des
raisons justement sanitaires pour que
dans quelques mois on ne soit pas obligé
de reconfirmer et de fermes et
éventuellement les établissements
scolaires ce qui serait vraiment une
catastrophe
arnaud farine riz rebondir ce cas allez
je vous en prie parents d'élèves qui est
extrêmement justes elle dit que si les
mesures avaient été prises
on aurait pu éviter sans doute une
partie de ce confinement
parce que nous depuis le début l'idée
c'était d'éviter le confinement et à
partir de là peut-être qu'il serait
quand même arriver parce qu'on n'est pas
devant d'accord mais il n'empêche que on
aurait pu largement atténué ce qui est
en train de se passer
enfin on a eu presque 2000 morts en une
semaine quand même 2000 mort du co vie
dans ma main et et surtout ce qui est
important c'est de se rendre compte que
ce même si les enfants
effectivement développe peu de mains peu
de symptômes graves il reste
contaminants on a plusieurs études là
dessus on est qu une étude qui a été
publié en juin
en israël on est une étude qui a été
publiée pour le coup parce langseth là
il ya quelques jours le 22 octobre
c'est quand même la principale revue
scientifique médicale britannique qui
dit clairement que les enfants peuvent
être extrêmement contaminant au même
titre que les adultes
ce qui veut donc dire que l'en les bras
ça 30 parfois dans trente mètres carrés
on voit bien le problème de jean michel
blanc coeur c'est que c'est quelqu'un
qui véritablement à une effet une idée
toute faite qui est l'idée que les
professeurs de lettres
au travail les familles doivent être au
travail et les enfants doivent être à
l'école mais le problème c'est que ça
réduit ça à l'école à une garderie les
professeurs à des gardes d'enfants et
les parents de simples travailleurs et
nous aussi d'ailleurs
justement on va faire réagir najat
belhassen c'est vrai qu'on entend
souvent à des parents dire que les
écoles restent ouvertes pour finalement
avoir le rôle de garderie et permettre
aux parents d'aller travailler est ce
que c'est le cas ce que vous partagez ce
constat écoutez je n'irai pas jusque là
parce que ça ne serait pas rendre
justice aux professeurs je suis désolé
aussi à mes jeux je pense que la
majorité des professeurs sont ce qu'ils
peuvent dans les conditions qui leur
sont attribués aujourd'hui la vraie
question c'est de savoir pour freiner le
virus et notamment chez les jeunes
adultes donc collégiens lycéens
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas justement
dit viser un peu ce nombre par classe de
façon à ce que l'on puisse maintenir les
écoles ouvertes vous savez les parents
ont vécu le confinement le premier
confinement d'une manière très brutale
et très difficile ou dans les
enseignants que les parents parce qu'il
a fallu faire et le télétravail à la
maison et l'école à la maison donc
c'était très dur
nous ce qu'on souhaiterait aujourd'hui
c'est d'apprendre de cette première
expérience est donc pour éviter
justement 1re confinement total avec une
fermeture des établissements l'école à
la maison
pourquoi pas envisager aujourd'hui parce
que la deuxième balle va bientôt arriver
de fer des deux groupes notamment au
collège et au lycée r parce que c'est là
aussi que le risque est plus fort de
façon à permettre en fait de laisser les
établissements scolaires ouverts éviter
le décrochage scolaire mais aussi
permettre en fait aux enfants de ne pas
se contaminer entre trop brutalement
parce que quand on a des groupes de 30
c'est pas des groupes de 15
donc quand on a 15 enfants bah on a
quinze fois la possibilité d'un facteur
de 2 d'être transmissibles alors que
quand on est 30 c'est ça ce qui
multiplie par 2 donc forcément on a
aussi des parents qui sont très fragiles
et donc
je ne suis pas sûr si vous voulez que la
mesure était tous tout au bout de ce
qu'elle pouvait faire je pense que en
plus de ça on parle beaucoup des
sanitaires
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que dans
les établissements scolaires les
sanitaires ne veut ne correspondent pas
à ce qu'on pourrait attendre en fait
dans une période comme la note de
pandémie donc il ya tout un programme je
pense est un projet qu'il faut qu'il
faut relancer qui est celui de donner à
l'école aujourd'hui de les moyens de
fonctionner même pendant une pandémie
comme on la connaît actuellement
arnaud arnaud fab le mot de la fin est
ce que finalement il faut maintenir
coûte que coûte les écoles ouvertes quel
que soit finalement le protocole
sanitaire qui kiziki l'important c'est
de faire en sorte que les que nous les
professeurs nous puissions continuer à
instruire nos élèves
si ça doit se faire à distance ça sera
distance mais si on peut l'éviter
je pense que les demis groupe que
réclame les parents d'élèves que réclame
elle est professeur et que le ministère
de l'éducation lui même ami dans son
protocole de juillet en cas
d'augmentation forte des contaminations
soit mis en place
enfin que le ministère assume ses
propres art et surtout les conséquences
de ses actes car ce n'est pas pour rien
que certains ont déjà porté plainte de
la queue devant la cour de justice de la
république pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui et que des perquisitions ont
commencé il y a là des choses très
graves qui se passait nos ministres
devant road rendre des comptes et en
attendant il faut absolument que l'école
ait lieu et d'une manière ou d'une autre
les demies groupe je pense c'est très
urgent merci merci à que les deux
d'avoir échangé sur notre antenne merci
arno fabre professeur de lettres
classiques administrateur national du
mouvement à des styles et rouge merci à
vous et najat belhassen vice présidente
de la fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves du val de marne est resté avec
nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la situation
en côte d'ivoire et la crainte de heurts
post-électoraux 48 heures après une
élection présidentielle controversée les
résultats devraient être annoncés dans
la soirée
et puis direction l'algérie la réforme
constitutionnelle a été approuvée par
référendum
avec une abstention record seuls 23
points 7 % des électeurs se sont
déplacés dans les bureaux de vote on se
retrouve dans un peu moins de cinq
minutes maintenant sur la france
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien pour rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
ses cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu
que c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usines et
autour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et 20 ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors par mois elle
s'était de nouveau brisé justement
délirer autour d'un dessert que j'ai
appelé la pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique le monde dames
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme s'est pas toute
fiabilité du projet ne serait ce qu'au
business et on oscille entre 92 et 80
18,5 pour cent ça fonctionne bien ça
permet un d'être rapide d'être non
invasif et puis d'avoir le résultat de
façon instantanée avec un coût qui est
quand même bien moindre plus que sont
les coûts actuels du pcr on va pas
sauver l'humanité souffrent pour
révolutionner les choses avec le travail
qu'on fait aux peut-être faire en sorte
qu'on fasse appel à un savoir faire et
un savoir faire médical aussi dans un
domaine un peu différente et celui de
l'animal mais après tout l'homme c'est
un animal populo
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative au sort
du cockpit
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
on l'apprend à l'instant plusieurs
attaques terroristes visant une
synagogue et un centre communautaire
juif et des restaurants seraient en
cours dans la ville de vienne en
autriche
un important dispositif policier avait
été déployé un bilan provisoire fait
état d'un mort et de plusieurs blessés
un des agresseurs un des agresseurs
seraient morts un autre en fuite selon
le ministère de l'intérieur cité par
l'agencé de presse autrichienne apa
plus d'informations à venir dans nos
prochaines éditions
le terme confinement se décline une
nouvelle fois dans les plus grandes
capitales d'europe le portugal a décrété
l'état d'urgence en pleine journée de
deuil national pour ces victimes du pôle
iiid à partir de mercredi plus de 7
millions de portugais seront re confinés
pendant au moins deux semaines
télétravail obligatoire commerces et
restaurants fermeront plus tôt nouvelles
mesures restrictives qui entrent
également en vigueur ce lundi en
allemagne la chancelière angela merkel
appelle ses citoyens à les respecter
pour parvenir je cite un tournant dans
sa veste à ce guide a retiré le rater
ces drames cela signifie que c'est entre
les mains de chacun de faire de ce mois
de novembre
notre succès commun de parvenir à un
tournant pour retrouver une traçabilité
de la pandémie
et si nous parvenons au cours des quatre
prochaines semaines à ralentir la
circulation du virus alors nous aurons
les conditions nécessaires à un mois de
décembre supportable en suivant bien sûr
encore les règles contre le corona virus
mais comme nous les connaissons depuis
plusieurs mois déjà mais avec plus de
liberté à miami et de son côté le
gouvernement italien durci le ton énième
restrictions à venir avec notamment la
fermeture le week-end des magasins non
essentiels dans les centres commerciaux
un couvre-feu national tard dans la
soirée est aussi à l'étude
je vous propose d'écouter le premier
ministre ghiz ep compter que vers la
mort à aimer un kémo same ans
malheureusement les musées les
expositions
vont fermer nous prévoyons également de
réduire à 50 % la capacité des
transports publics et de réduire la
mobilité en provenance et à destination
des régions où le taux d'infection est
élevé sauf en cas de déplacement pour le
travail les études la santé une
situation de nécessité
c'est la volonté montrés des studios
odessa l'hôte est celle de la chef
d'état
et puis en belgique 2e confinement de
six semaines dès ce matin les magasins
d'un essentiels ont fermé leurs rideaux
le télétravail est devenu obligatoire
les écoles elle reste fermée jusqu'au 15
novembre
seule bonne nouvelle contrairement à la
france les librairies peuvent toujours
accueillir des clients sont absolument
se libère deux triste de la situation
dans laquelle ils sont et triste pour
leurs lecteurs évidemment c'est déjà
plus simple que la première fois parce
qu'on peut selon peut se balader dans la
ville
on n'a pas de restriction n'est pas
obligé de rester à la maison donc on
marche on se balade et quand il ya
quelques magasins ouverts et on essaye
d'y aller par amp les librairies même
temps dans la guerre on n'a pas fermé
les librairies et on produisait même du
papier de la basse qualité pour pourrait
publier des livres non qui s'était coc
fascinant ça démontre que les gens au
pouvoir
ne s'intéressent plus aux livres et dans
le reste de l'actualité une élection à
hauts risques la présidentielle en côte
d'ivoire avant les résultats qui
pourraient tomber ce soir l'opposition
annonce qu'elle va former un
gouvernement de transition en attendant
la crainte de heurts post électoraux est
dans tous les esprits au moins deux
morts le jour du scrutin samedi auquel
s'ajoutent de nouvelles victimes dans un
village situé à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de yamoussoukro c'est la
capitale administrative ivoirienne
la tension règne également du côté
d'abidjan la capitale économique aura
tout de suite faire le point sur place
avec nos envoyés spéciaux samantha
ramsamy est clair un ep samantha bonsoir
alors vous êtes à la commission
électorale indépendante ivoirienne dans
la tente comme la population de
l'annoncé des résultats officiels du
premier tour du scrutin présidentiel
oui à l'annoncé des résultats officiels
est donc prévue ce soir peut-être aux
alentours de 22 heures un peu après ça
se fera via la télévision nationale
comme d'habitude la rti qui est
d'ailleurs installé vous le voyez
derrière nous ces studios des résultats
sans surprise le président sortant
alassane ouattara devrait s'imposer à la
faveur du boycott de l'opposition en
tout cas des résultats livrés 48 heures
après le scrutin et hier déjà on a senti
un peu la pression monte ici à abidjan
avec un renforcement de la sécurité
ce matin la ville était beaucoup plus
animée reprise du travail oblige on le
rappelle ce week end la capitale
économique étaient quasi désertes mais
on notera quand même qu'aujourd'hui le
trafic était très fluide d'une commune à
une autre ce qui nous a permis de nous
rendre dans une commune défavorisée et
populaire yopougon kouté
là bas nous avons
tenter de parler avec les habitants
beaucoup ont refusé de s'exprimer devant
nos caméras mais pour ce qu'ils ont fait
eh bien ils ont exprimé la peur qu'il
ressentait à la proche de l' annonce de
ses résultats
ils craignent en effet de revivre
nouvelle crise post électorale on
rappelle que celle de 2010 2011 a fait
au moins 3000 morts un mot important
quand même sur la situation dans le sud
du pays
et bien la situation elle reste très
tendue là bas on notera qu'à bouaké le
fief de l'ex chef rebelle guillaume soro
eh bien il ya eu des affrontements
intercommunautaires aujourd'hui autre
fief de l'opposition daoukro là bas on a
noté des manifestations alors savons pas
quelle est l'atmosphère politique
alors le bras de fer entre l'opposition
et le pouvoir s'est durci depuis samedi
en cause le déroulement du scrutin dans
le sud du pays plusieurs régions ont été
empêchés de voter à l'appel de à la
désobéissance civile lancé par
l'opposition
du coup le pays on le sait ils déplorent
plusieurs morts mais c'est très très
difficile en réalité de s'avancer au
moment où je vous parle sur un un bilan
réel
pascal affi n'guessan et l'ancien
président henri konan-bédié et bien ils
ont appelé à un gouvernement de
transition civile dont ils ont tellement
c'est la création
aujourd'hui on le rappelle ils n'ont pas
voté et cet après midi pour tenter
d'apaiser la situation
l'onu devait dépêcher une délégation à
la résidence d'henri konan bédié
du côté du rhdp en tout cas on continue
d'affirmer que rien n'entache la
crédibilité de ce scrutin la mission
d'observation de la cedeao la communauté
des états d'afrique de l'ouest abonde
dans ce sens à la donner une conférence
de presse aujourd'hui
même son de cloche d'ailleurs du côté de
la commission électorale indépendante le
pouvoir qui réfute un rapport d'une ong
indigo qui indique que 23 % des bureaux
de vote n'ont pas ouvert samedi dernier
par ailleurs plusieurs missions
d'observation électorale note que cette
élection laisse un pays fracturée
depuis un samedi on note vraiment qu'une
guerre de communication fait rage entre
le pouvoir et l'opposition qui
multiplient les points presse tour à
tour une guerre de communication qui est
alimenté par les réseaux sociaux qui
publie des vidéos susceptibles de
troubler et d'induire en erreur
l'opinion publique ivoirienne voilà la
situation qui reste tendue dans le pays
ce soir merci beaucoup savons pas pour
toutes ces précisions samantha ramsamy
en direct d'abidjan où on retrouvera
bien évidemment pour commenter les
résultats de cette présidentielle
et on continue de parler de la situation
en côte d'ivoire avec louis keumayou
président du club de l'information
africaine bonsoir louis keumayou merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors appel au boycott de l'opposition
actes de violence non participation
plusieurs candidats compte tenu du
contexte les résultats qui doivent être
connus très prochainement est-ce qu'ils
vont être ils vont être accepté par la
population
nous sommes dans une élection
présidentielle qui est qui se tient dans
un contexte vraiment très précaire non
seulement le président qui se présente
avait dit qu'il ne se représenterait pas
mais qu'il a dû le faire à la suite du
décès du premier ministre amadou gon
coulibaly qui a été désigné comme le
candidat de sa famille politique
il ya eu tout ce débat qui a occulté le
le tout le débat sur le programme du
candidat celui sur l'anti
constitutionnalité d'une troisième
mandat possible le rsa doit être ça que
c'est le premier contexte le deuxième
qu'il faut pas ignorer non plus c'est
qu'au sein même de la famille du rhdp
il ya eu beaucoup de défections il ya
notamment guillaume soro qui était le
patron de la branche armée qui est parti
il était présent à l'assemblée nationale
où il a quitté sa famille politique et à
d'autres membres de la coalition qui ont
quitté également le navire du rhdp
notamment haricots en belgique et qui
est ancien président la république
ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale également
donc c'est un contexte dans lequel on
n'a pas eu un vrai débat politique
on a eu énormément de tension qui se
sont cristallisées et puis il faut pas
oublier tous les morts qui a eu à en
même le jour de l'élection et pendant
les élections tous les barrages qui eut
pour empêcher l'élection de se tenir
et évidemment il ya aussi ce mot d'ordre
de désobéissance civile qui a été lancé
par l'opposition et qui arrangerait
compliquer la tenue du scrutin
donc c'est vrai que c'est une élection
qui n'est pas facile mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait annuler le résultat de cette
élection
l'enjeu était de mon point de vue
ailleurs
parce que pour le président ouattara
l'idée c'était de ne pas être dans
l'illégitimité politique en heure un
jour au delà du délai constitutionnel
qui lui est accordée pour l'opposition
il ne fallait pas du tout que l'élection
se tient donc les deux se sont battus
chacun avec les arguments qui étaient
les leurs et soi même avec des éléments
qui relevait du vandalisme et finalement
l'élection a eu lieu on verra la
proclamation des résultats
comment les ivoires et accueilleront
cela les ivoiriens des gueux bord parce
que ce n'est pas un bloc monolithique
les champs politiques sont récents très
perceptible les champs ethnique
également d'or dans les choix est donc
finalement c'est c'est un véritable bras
de fer qui va se manifester après le
résultat les urnes pour savoir si le
pays sera gouverné ou pas alors le parti
au pouvoir en attendant a mis en garde
l'opposition contre toute tentative de
déstabilisation
est ce que l'on peut craindre de réelles
tensions dans les jours qui vont venir
la tension est déjà là ce n'est pas pour
les jours à venir cela peut-être que
rhin une montée en puissance de la
violence comme je leur devais tout à
l'heure et alicia toutes ces violences
qui a eu juste parce que il ya eu le
débat sur la constitutionnalité ou pas
du troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
qui a fait plus d'une trentaine de morts
il ya toutes les violences qui se sont
produits pendant les élections
et puis à tout ce qui s'est fait en
marge de l'élection parce qu'il ya des
maisons qui ont été volés lors certaines
régions il ya les violences
intercommunautaires qui se sont
également produites et ont débouché sur
des morts d'hommes dont tient déjà la
violente
est ce qu'après cela vu qu'il ya un
gouvernement de transition qui a été
fait un peu comme sur le modèle de celui
de l'hôtel du golf
quand le président wever a revendiqué sa
victoire en 2010 et qu'il n'était pas
reconnue ni par la commission électorale
ni par la cour constitutionnelle et une
rien gouvernants transition qui a été
monté en parallèle on verra comment tout
cela se passera mais c'est très
difficile
au moment où on se parle d'avoir une
projection clair les observateurs ont
des avis mitigés
cette commission dont on parle et indigo
cette association
elle a donné son pronostic mais les
accréditations nombre de bureaux de vote
à ses limites et au final parce que
c'est moins de 10% des bureaux de vote
qui ont vu le passage de indigo et donc
que vos l'analyse de indigo par rapport
à la situation globale sur les 94% des
bureaux de vote minutes sont passées de
rien tous ces éléments qui font que
aujourd'hui on est dans une vraie
situation de flou et je pense que les
leaders politiques devraient se
comporter en leader et essayer d'apaiser
le climat politique qui est de plus en
plus tendue alors vous parlais justement
de cette question constitutionnelle la
candidature d'alassane ouattara à un
troisième mandat
est ce qu'elle aurait pu être tranché
sereinement avant ces élections
non parce que la bataille d'abord
interne ou rhdp le lancement de souffre
et east pour la démocratie et la paix
c'est l'intérieur de ce rassemblement
politique que la question aurait dû être
tranchée l'alliance que alassane
ouattara a fait avec ses partenaires
aussi bien guillaume sourire que henri
konan bédié et tous les autres membres
du rhdp était telle que le rdr qui est
le parti originel de alassane ouattara
ne devait pas présenter de candidat
après 2015 c'est ce qui se dit je n'ai
pas d'éléments pour le vérifier mais il
était question qui est au sein de la
famille un passage de relais
ce passage de relais n'a pas eu lieu et
donc c'est pour cette raison
principalement que le choix de amadou
gon coulibaly avait déjà été contestée
puis quand le président ouattara lui
même a dû aller au charbon pour défendre
les couleurs de sa famille politique et
a eu encore des désistements
n'oublions pas que constitutionnellement
en côte d'ivoire il ya un premier
ministre
mais également un vice-président et que
ce vice-président là aujourd'hui a
démissionné n'a pas été remplacé donc il
ya un vrai débat au sein du rhdp pour
savoir il ya eu un débat pour savoir si
le président ouattara devait aller
haricots en baie d'hyères considérés
comme non les autres membres de
tu as à me voir aussi et donc du coup le
président ouattara a fait confiance à
ceux qui le soutenaient le plus et qui
appelait à sa candidature il l'a fait au
détriment de l'alliance que qui l'avait
porté au pouvoir en 2010 merci beaucoup
le oui le mailloux d'avoir partagé votre
aval il rappelle que vous êtes président
du club de l'information africaine au
référendum constitutionnel
en algérie cette fois sens et fonder une
nouvelle république victoire du oui avec
66,8 % mais les algériens ont boudé
massivement les urnes le taux de
participation final ne s'élève qu'à 23
7% à les opposants dont les militants du
irak ont appelé au boycott
même si le mouvement de contestation est
moins visible plus que les marcheurs
hebdomadaire les marchés hebdomadaires
pardon sont suspendus à cause de la
crise sanitaire
leur appel semble donc avoir été entendu
et pour en parler nous sommes avec sow
agba by sa vice présidente de l'alliance
des démocrates de la diaspora algérienne
souad sbai sa merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on le
disait large majorité de oui pour la
réforme constitutionnelle mais une
abstention record
quel bilan vous pouvez faire de ce
scrutin historique pour moi d'abord je
dirais que c'est la victoire du chirac
c'est la victoire de la révolution du
sourire et ce n'est certainement pas la
victoire de cette région delà de la
région algéroise et peu ceux de ce
système politique
les algériens et les algériennes ont
vraiment dit que il confirme que il
rejette ce pouvoir politique et que de
toute façon un seul projet de 2,2
constitution ne ne les concerne pas
parce que de toute façon il n'est pas
l'émanation de la souveraineté nationale
il n'a pas été dans le processus d'une
constituant un don qu'il y à vraiment
aujourd'hui une rupture inéluctable
entre le peuple algérien et cette caste
poli
et d'ailleurs on le voit bien même au
niveau de la participation
eux qui avaient pour habitude
d'organiser la fraude d'avoir une
clientèle qui étaient là dans le milieu
militaire de la police des petits
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui même cette
clientèle là ils n'ont pas su la
rassembler elle n'a pas répondu présent
et le véritable taux de participation il
est 2 % c'est ça la réalité ils n'ont
pas réussi à mobiliser un tiers de leur
clientèle habituelle et donc on voit
bien que ce système politique que c'est
free que la bbc et que nous avons un
résultat qui fabriqué pour faire croire
à l'opinion internationale qu'il ya des
gisements ligne a aucune légitimité à ce
pouvoir politique
le peuple algérien le rejet et on l'a vu
même si il y à eut un instrumental
isation ducobu le 19 ou empêcher les
marches
le peuple a exprimé aujourd'hui
southwell d'un véritable changement est
d'arriver à l'auto détermination et même
je dirais j'irai plus loin c'est que
même la révolution du sourire nous amène
vers une véritable rupture car même le
populisme des islamistes n'a pas réussi
à avoir un poids significatif avec son
nom à ce qui a l'habitude on le sait il
est toujours du côté de la région sadji
roises il est toujours là pour tenter 2
de se placer de trouver une légitimité
ben non c'est un véritable échec de ce
référendum
c'est un désaveu de ce pouvoir et ça ou
solide la rupture et dell dans cette
revendication du peuple algérien après
ce désaveu alors après ce désaveu
justement tel avenir voyez-vous
pour pour l'algérie est ce qu'il y à des
figures qui se démarquent comment est-ce
que ça va pouvoir maintenant j'en sais
lorsque j'adore toujours c'est qu'on
nous demande toujours est ce qu'il y à
des figures qui se dit ma je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le camp démocratique a
gagné parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment ancrée maintenant dans la
société algérienne
cette société algérienne lb a changé
elle met à nu processus elle ne manque
demande pas aujourd'hui à avoir des
figures qui est mal elle demande une
transition démocratique avec un
processus de constituants c'est c'est ça
l'avenir
et aujourd'hui il va falloir que ce
pouvoir qui en place en prennent
conscience et que là que le camp
démocratique au prennent aujourd'hui
c'est lui qui domine parce que la
population algérienne
elle va ce changement-là plus de ce
système politique sale et il est fini il
est on désaveu total il n'avait déjà pas
de légitimité à l'issue des élections du
12 décembre 2010 n'a hélas le désaveu
passe à ce référendum
ils ont bu de la plébiscitent ils ne
l'ont pas eu et l'avenir est entre les
mains du camp démocrate
il faut qu'ils en prennent conscience
merci beaucoup soad baba aïssa d'avoir
réagi sur notre antenne je rappelle que
vous êtes vice présidente de l'alliance
des démocrates de la diaspora algérienne
et c'est la fin de cette émission mais
restez avec nous on va se retrouver dans
quelques minutes dans un peu moins de
dix minutes pour un nouveau point
complet sur l'actualité a tout de suite
sur rt france
[Musique]
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et et la préparer
il ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter 20 à 30% de son
pipe pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur
vous nous expliquer qu effectivement le
réveil va être compliqué il va être
douloureux il ya eu un moment de très
grand relâchement et nous sommes en
train de payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes commencent